Sol's an actual and password Raymond's  an excellent defender blocking Tony  Allen saw and then the ramp is a  beautiful block on Allen cycle greens  sneaking along the baseline  Greymon block tale dream on picked his  pocket again at steal number seven it's  efficient against Memphis and playing  great basketball can they sustain it all  games play reloads free is down  Devon loading experience as he is  doubling Gasol smartly now ins not a  great finisher Greymon with a block  Allen put it back up  Randolph inside in his home take the  starters out yes for starters in  Iguodala there's Durant's moving without  the ball dream on finding him you can do  that offensively or defensively Conley  with the jumper rattles out this all  inside Trayvon with a block